Sam was looking at the boat and saying
okay so checkmate in two moves which
tells me that I remember what we
actually said last week right we said
we're going to continue with checkmate
in two moves right and how did it
usually remind me same was the second
before the asking question so but very
good if if we all remember deny also can
remember what we said alrighty so
checkmate in too much
now Sam do you know the answer also yes
Queen take eight seven and if the King
will take your queen that's pretty
convincing
no then ah the work the work is going to
be here and the night will capture it
it's a legal right the night will move
in an l-shape take take and check look
h5 right and that that pretty much looks
like a checkmate
all right excellent job it is one okay
if it looks like a checkmate if it walks
like a checkmate smells like a checkmate
it's a checkmate now I know no I'll just
put this position how white plays you
what do you say Adi 97 I'm not knocking
on it because Ben once told me you
should have put it on like YouTube
funniest team like how I stayed like
this in a moment to stop heart attack
and bless the microphones everywhere all
right
97 that's it I quit
see you tomorrow next week oh wait was
Queen at 7:00 why not 97 because it's
not given thank you it doesn't have to
take its first time in my life I heard
that right after saying it about
thousands of times if you play night of
7 does black have to take so how so why
why would that be false checkmate you
want him to take yeah but if job is not
to take remember what we've said
checkmate in two move means you really
see every possibility the best ones who
you and your opponent and play
accordingly that's really important on
the other end after Queen of seven no
this is really important black has to
take so there is no question maybe could
be would be should be checkmate it's
really really important and you know it
happens in some games in puzzles that
are not check me that people assume that
if they will sacrifice something the
opponent has to take but it doesn't it's
really really important the opponent
doesn't have to take the opponent just
like you have to play what is best right
ok this is our beautiful position and it
is white to play like why to play
checkmating today at what we have here I
suggest to we will think and then we
will raise up you think you have the
right answer you're certain you have the
right answer
and it should be 5 what would black play
actually what to black play then change
okay it's very very very important to to
think we are not in a competition not
here and definitely not I would say in a
funny way not also in the game now don't
explode don't explode I'm taking cover
now it's much more important to be
correct then to be fast right much more
important in chess and out of chess
seriously yeah if you tell me hey you
have a test in school and you have one
hour to answer hundred questions yeah
you don't you can no it's probably not
going to be a great idea to think for 20
minutes about answering one question no
right by the way what you should do here
my big tip form school you should answer
everything that you know as quickly as
possible let's say you answer 90 out of
hundred quickly then you come back to
the ten that you didn't answer and then
you can take your time right because it
would be it wouldn't make sense to get
stuck at one question for 20 minutes you
will get it correct but you wouldn't be
able to answer 20 questions now back
from school to chess but it's not that
weighing chest
you cannot go further and then come back
so much more important to think properly
in the right moment take your time you
know a World Championship game or a game
in a grandmaster tournament that was in
this club there were several grand after
tournament right here in st. Louis
including the world champion current
world champion Magnus Carlsen how long
do you think each game can last
Moe like most of the game depends on
time control can last somewhere between
four five to six hours yeah that was an
average of a game depends on the time
control four to six hours one game so
you take your time when you're gonna
play in kids level you are correct
you're getting about 30 30 minutes per
player in most kids tournament yes what
would be our answer and the work is
gonna take this is very very correct
because we shall be filed that we
suggested that was suggested right it
looked like checkmate but well black is
gonna block and that would that was the
problem that you got stuck with right so
we so we're thinking in our head we
should be 5 denied blocking now
checkmate right ok so then what should
be our next step in thinking how can we
prevent the knight form blocking so
maybe we can eliminate it by the way
what happens if you take and black move
this King that's also a legal move yes
still this should be 5 I think also 95
would be checkmate right but this would
be 5 so we're going to take and does it
matter if black movies can go block
movies King Saul your capture but most
important thing we are not in a race
like seriously for any for anyone here
and in general take your time you have
even if you have 30 minutes if you are
taught in a game for 3 minutes 5 minutes
play the right move the game is over you
don't need to bother after it your idea
was right we need the right way to get
it to work white is to play
making to that all that we are doing for
now
okay
what would black play very good by the
way if white pawn was on g3 would it
still be working or not why not
perfect very good very good
so it's similar to the idea was that
your idea kind of what was the idea you
want it first to take the night the
important thing look when we see the
King on the h5 and the king cannot step
aside well it means that if we can do
something on the h-file we might win the
game
maybe immediately the king is kind of
trapped it's almost like the back rent
it's almost like the back rank the
h-file so we play check black has to
take and now we open the file check me
and there was one way yeah it basically
kind of discovered check me whites to
play in all positions unless I say
differently whites to play and most
puzzles in most books to be white to
play any help
okay excellent if it's like if it's left
to play checkmate in one so Adi what
would you play second time I forgive
third time to the guillotine right yeah
okay we'll teach you about friends after
it you maybe be laughing a bit less once
we speak about that but in Italy I know
why you said the same thing because it
said 97 he will take and checkmate right
but what was just said before not only
you wouldn't take it but you will play
this tiny move you want to force your
reply right Knight Queen take a
seven-night take checkmate idea their
direction where the checkmate will be
right but the way all right so now I'm
going to just make tiny changes to this
position I'm going to put this pawn here
I'm going to put this Knight here we're
going to put this one here and I'm going
to put the Queen here the Queen here
actually how am I going to create it I'm
going to make it like this okay this is
a serious position
let's see black is threatening checkmate
is threatening to take is threatening to
take Mamma Mia this is scary
Black has many many many checkmate to it
I will let you all okay but I will let
you all of two minutes and then we can
answer
yes
but how is it gonna be checkmate you're
attacking the Queen and actually black
is going to checkmate is going to take
the pawn right because it's different
yes yes okay the bishop has to take
right and then Kate was this your answer
very good I was just going to ask that
exactly exactly that that idea by the
way this this pattern this pattern
let's look tiny bit at this pattern
because it's not a bad one so let's say
this is our position
how does white checkmate in two moves
say I am you won't tell me and it that
will be checkmate in two moves and if
the King who goes to b8
this is someone I know but you want it
first to play this small very good yes
one day egg what I know I have no clue
surely maybe I do
oh I don't know how it even came there
why was it back to me
that's way because the no but the fire
one was white to play so weird maybe on
their way back in anyway yes and our
basics matters mate
and many times you know you can see
those combinations we can go more moves
ahead for example if I will set the
position here and tell you checkmate in
three moves and so on and so on it
basically just will be a pattern that we
will keep looking and looking that the
final idea will be check give the Queen
a 97 checkmate right so that pattern
okay
tiny bit in our head there's gonna be
checkmate in two moves let me see the
type yes kind of I like this world kind
of it's like think about the two teacher
in school tell you re you got a kind of
it's actually a D kind of right it's
kind of its two letters apart right
just being cm in the middle yes what
will okay if there's a difference to
this checkmate maybe I didn't put
something correctly but but if there's a
difference to the checkmate so maybe you
don't see the right move
could it be that your move is wrong and
if there is the Chapman that there is no
defense
oh yeah
what is the checkmate okay here we made
it extra funny okay but delay that shows
me that there is no defense at least I
hope I really hope that I we're gonna
think we are going to thank you you know
know maybe why to play
clueless
okay now we know the answer maybe what
to play okay but what is your threat
even after Bishop e6 well let's say I do
not here I play delete the meaningless
move now you need to show me checkmate
in one move one move checkmate right you
wasted one move yes but I can go to g7
you could have played you could have
played Luke h8 here why is Bishop e6 you
know the bishop is defending this pawn
from a2 from east six it's not like you
need the bishop on e6 for extra
protections for f7 doesn't change
anything so this is not gonna but what
is going to make this one well in the
Bell you've been extremely quiet let's
see you see that's what I like not
saying much but when saying something
saying the smartest things that's very
very correct very correct that's the way
it should be
well why would a cheat is no checkmate
we need to ask yourself why would a
cheat is no checkmate because the King
can go to g7 so everything that you will
play not preventing that is not going to
change anything now what was really
important for me when I put this
position this way this is a threat of a
checkmate the bishop can be captured but
it doesn't matter it can be captured
thousand different ways black but it's
not checked right
but doesn't have any check but how there
is upon I mean of course we play when
the opponent sees your best move but
black when I say checkmate in two moves
it means if your opponent Lee is perfect
well how do we prevent checkmate you
here is the thing that there is another
possibility if when white will play rook
h8 if the pawn here will be undefended
who is defending the pawn the be sure
because the hawk will move so let's see
if we can play move to block it but if
you block this is checkmate this why I
kept putting the position it was
important that there will be for example
an idea because if there is no knight
black will play walk before if you take
is rook captures if you play walk check
so that way it was very tricky white had
to keep the possibility of two things
one would h8 and the second one that if
this diagonal is blocked that taking the
walk is a possibility okay if we
understand like what Isabel said we need
to take the put black take away the g7
square we solved it very good
why he's to play
that's what we said for today
why to move in checkmate in two moves
Oh
yes okay perfect
when you say when when I get white
answers I just say perfect right that's
what I want I didn't have to say
anything
this is the position and why to
checkmate in one move
no Sam you don't get to answer yes okay
that's an idea I'm not saying if you try
to walk I want to hear I want to hear
other thoughts
I want to hear other thought wait no no
no okay so we need to think more right
the east I will say thousand times
because there is no point in saying
something in ten second five seconds
after it understanding by yourself why
it's wrong take the five seconds and
don't say something wrong it's a bear
that has been so quiet I will always
give favor you're quiet you get it yes
Isabel what what yeah very you make them
so happy oh my goodness like it's like
someone just scored a touchdown
that's that that's a very very smart
very very good comment then okay so you
see like I said Ben is the living spirit
of here but without him the meanness
that are watching us right now on
YouTube would not end this position and
I'm not joking but that's always pretty
I really like like those puzzles very
very nice castle because the king why
did I have to put the pawn here because
if not King if ii would also be winning
basically you need to move the king from
the first rank but not block here so the
king could have gone here but castle is
very pretty your question how do we know
that there is no castle excellent
question yeah i but i didn't want to say
assuming white could white castle
because then it would me be so easy
why to play one answer seriously super
seriously one answer
do we know IIIi will let everyone else
take another 1 minute and then you can
tell me okay
are you certain you orbit right that's
not bad
I will wait and see okay I want to see
one more hand but be careful because if
I might I have to ask you the question
yes I see one more hand oh it what shall
we play he's Lukey seven checkmate
let's see check
kingi five is the only move walk e7 the
King goes to d4 right so we have to be
careful yes but it can be captured yes
the bishop will capture it Plus even if
the bishop doesn't capture if you go
here huh yes but there is no check you
will not have checked it after it no but
there's not even a check there's no
threat if you PlayBook see it I mean you
have to check it plus if you are not
going to check black is going to check
white and there will be no checkmate in
two moves so you have to check you have
to but how to check might here twinky
one
this is a bit tricky but you know very
close very close how re kingi five very
good all you need to do is prevent
escaping squares of the king and both of
those the bishop and the bishop will be
checking so we need to take this is the
important part we cannot solve such
puzzles without going through the right
process what I want to do what the
opponent how what and how the opponent
can prevent it only if you tell yourself
okay I'll move my look my opponent can
go to default on a foe if I can move the
c-7 hook and prevent it from going to d4
for it will be a checkmate you have to
go into your head the thing is it's two
really strong players it's autumn we'll
take a second
but for us beginners it's taking a bit
longer but that's the right process when
you do these thousands of thousands of
thousands of times it will be much much
much faster excellent job Adi
checkmate very similar to the answer
that we had only very similar the answer
was quite okay not this one we will have
a mystery chapter for next week
mystery chapter all right so I will see
you next Sunday
you